it's it's less about a particular
organization or a particular activity
it's about whether or not you've given
the money in such a way that you can
actually have some confidence that it's
going to make the change in the world
you want and that change can be you know
having another student at risk of
dropping out actually being able to
graduate on time that change could be
getting a existing cost effective drug
for malaria to a child in time that you
save that person's life I distinguish
between high-impact philanthropy and
other types of philanthropy because some
philanthropy isn't practiced in such a
way that it can assure those kinds of
results in fact many philanthropists
don't necessarily give with the idea of
trying to maximize the social good of
their philanthropy so for those folks
who are giving out of a sense of
obligation or reciprocal giving my
buddies on a board he gave money to my
fundraiser so I gave money to his
fundraiser or you know I don't care so
much about I'm speaking from the point
of view of philanthropist I don't care
so much about whether or not I am really
maximizing the impact of my gift but I'm
really happy that my name is on that big
building so that's high-impact
philanthropy is different from that kind
of social or reciprocal philanthropy in
that it's squarely focused on improving
the lives of others all philanthropy
especially high impact philanthropy
where people are really focusing on
results it starts with a personal
commitment and so you know this is it's
a personal commitment to making a change
in the world and how people got to that
commitment is a very unique and personal
journey I don't think you want to
disrupt that journey because one of the
things with high-impact philanthropy is
you have to have a commitment to ongoing
learning there are no silver bullets so
you have
to be able to care enough about the
issue to learn when you've goofed up and
to redirect or add more resources than
you thought you needed in order to
achieve your good and what's exciting is
when a philanthropist says I'm committed
to making a change in this area whatever
that area is once you get to that point
then you say great how can you translate
that commitment and those good
intentions and whatever resources you're
bringing to the table to actually making
the difference you want to make you know
that that's where hopefully our work
plays is to to translate those good
intentions and that commitment to
actually